I hear this this movie is darker than
the last one no yes it is although I
feel like when the Harry Potter series
came out but each time there's a new a
new book or a new film it was always
like there's some light relief in this
fellow who's back starting yeah I love
that you guys are fascinated by our view
it is yes and Judis loves it
do you joining the cast yeah the young
love how was that very young which makes
it a little better delicious delicious
like he's a little younger he's still
mischievous and he can be manipulative
ah he he has a great friendship with
Newt Newt was a student of his a student
that he championed there's a little bit
of a past there which i think is already
known right under the Newt was asked to
leave Hogwarts and Dumbledore trying to
stand up for him and Newt has this
capacity to always act in the right way
for the right reason and it's something
that Dumbledore relies on in this
situation because Dumbledore cannot get
involved in the the confrontation that
is at the heart of this film so new is
he sort of conduit basically Dumbledore
exploits we break it down or break it
down and make it easy um how much fun
wasn't working together and working with
the special effects too because this
movie has great special effects
we're so lucky that we like each other
do you really and then we were so lucky
that the new people were also appealing
humans so we really scored I mean but
also for us I'm one of the things for
today I found extraordinary women
because we you know you make the films
and there is a certain amount of
green-screen all that stuff when we
don't get to see it until events like
this and so seeing some of the effects
come to life it's good to see there's a
moment we're finding some creatures yeah
and we're in front of green screen and
they just kind of explained what was
happening and we're still waiting for
like okay yeah but then cut to us just
you can on the floor with nothing around
us just like
playback we look so crazy but hopefully
they'll put something there it would be
like have you guys ever seen Alfred
Hitchcock's Birds without the birds all
the birds just about take us up straight
who knew that Johnny Depp was coming did
anybody know the weird one was that we
didn't know he was in the first movie at
all hmm I mean we Shawn jeans without
him and they put him in with just a few
people so I didn't even know he is
looking at his face I was like we should
meet Johnny I was like who you didn't
have that on your head when you met them
no of course okay I have what on my head
but I heard the crowd were crazy and
that it really helped it just made for a
magical moment at the panel their lives
they live their lives and then when he
started speaking it went silent you
couldn't hear a pin drop it was amazing
yeah but that makes for the great moment
right yeah it was it was really really
fun moment yeah so what was it like
being a part of this room yeah you're
stepping into an entire universe um and
of course growing up with Harry Potter
and actually being on set being handed a
wand meeting JK I mean it's it's an
incredible experience and everyone was
so welcoming I think I was quite nervous
I mean even when I was auditioning Eddie
you were so wonderful
I mean here's this week no but really it
was I walked into a very warm
environment and it made it a really
great place to to feel safe to to
explore the depths of these Karen and
I'll never forget yours when Zoe
auditioned for it all screen tested for
it we were doing the first film because
she was in your photograph in the
photograph and it was the first time
that I had seen scenes from the second
second and I had no idea really what our
relationship wasn't we're trying to
figure it out as I was happening here
and by the way which carrot which has
more sinister characters big little lies
very different different types of
sinister I almost want to see scarier
photo you just it's you know it's based
in reality that's a little that's scary
you know they have brunch with a dream
about him
[Applause]
you
[Music]